hamas militants say they've fired
hundreds of rockets towards tel aviv
in retaliation for israeli air strikes
including one
that destroyed this here 12-story
residential block in the gaza strip
video footage shows the tower housing
and office used by hamas leaders
collapsing israel deployed more than 80
jets to bomb gaza
and massed tanks on the border as rocket
barrages hit israeli towns
the latest violence has killed dozens of
civilians in gaza and at least
three israelis
all right let's go straight now to our
correspondent tanya kramer she is in
jerusalem
good evening to you tanya it has been
quite a day
tell us what is going on on the ground
now
well airstrikes by the israeli military
continue on the gaza strip as well as
rockets are being fired from militant
groups hamas and
islamic jihad now as you already
mentioned
shortly before nine o'clock local time
nine pm local time
the air sirens went off in the tel aviv
area also in the center of the country
and the massive rocket barrage was
launched from gaza towards tel aviv
that's always seen here
as a major development also as a red
line usually for the
israeli government we understand that
one
person in this barrage was killed near
sean lesion and several people were
injured
also for over an hour the international
airport ben gurion
was closed international air traffic was
re-routed to cyprus
in hamas said in a statement they fired
at least 130
rockets towards tel aviv in retaliation
to the strike on the residential
building uh in gaza
which also was home to many families
there that evacuated
uh before the strike so
it was a very uh deadly day also we know
about 28
people killed in gaza with children
included
and three israelis killed tanya we're
looking at live pictures right now
we were looking at live pictures of tel
aviv
and we understand that prime minister
benjamin netanyahu and
israel's defense minister they've been
speaking on what did they say about
what's happened today
well absolutely they gave a rather a
short
statement just earlier
and prime minister benjamin netanyahu
said that
the militant groups in gaza will pay a
heavy price
and they will continue to do so the idf
chief of staff said that over 500
targets in gaza were
hit and prime minister netanyahu was
also saying
that this will take some time
to bring back safety here to the people
in israel
and there is concern that this is just
the beginning that this could
continue to escalate what are you
hearing
yeah we are expecting somehow that this
might intensify
even overnight there are some reports in
the garden
media saying that israel has warned to
target
more of the high-rise buildings that are
mostly also residential buildings in
gaza
and hamas and islamic jihad have already
said if that happens they will continue
to strike areas like tel aviv and even
further north
so this would be a further escalation
what is already a very
uh tense situation uh
so to speak so it seems there's not much
room for maneuvering right now
nobody is actually capable of breaking
this cycle at the moment gw's tonya
kramer with the latest tonight from
jerusalem tanya thank you very much
this is the latest escalation as
tensions in the region boil over into
bloodshed gaza health officials
say an earlier round of israeli air
strikes killed dozens of people
including several children
a father kisses his son one last time
the 11 year old boy was killed after
israel launched retaliatory strikes on
gaza
officials there say nine children died
in the attack
why did you kill him they kill and there
is no one to make them answer for it
the whole world is watching it doesn't
matter if it's a child or a woman
there is no one to hold them accountable
hours before hamas militants fired a
barrage of rockets from the palestinian
enclave
the cross-border attacks which began on
monday mark
a major escalation in violence
israel's prime minister warned that the
fighting could continue
for some time
we are in a fight on several fronts
jerusalem gaza and elsewhere in this
country
this evening on jerusalem day the
terrorist organizations in gaza have
crossed a red line
and attacked us with missiles in the
outskirts of jerusalem
the catalyst for the violence was
israel's plans to evict a number of
palestinian families from east jerusalem
to make room for jewish settlers
jerusalem's al-aqsa mosque compound a
sacred site to both muslims and jews
has also been at the center of tensions
in recent weeks
the international community has repeated
its calls for de-escalation